yeah and you use gold in your book uh as
a statement of reference which is
something that most people are familiar
with one question that I did pop into my
mind when I was reading your book was
whether the phenomena you're describing
um are tied to the rise of crypto over
like the this last period of time
because it it seems like people have
been casting about for in some ways
alternative to Fiat currencies that
aren't gold uh is is that something that
uh that you think is an outgrowth of of
what you're describing it has the form
together
um of what is money
I mean it's Genesis what is money and
how can we not only digitalize it which
makes it some extent efficient but also
the real questions can it maintain value
so it will not be depreciated by central
banks that's a that's that's a key thing
can it be transferred used all around
the world accepted for purchases and
sales all around the world then it has
to do with issues like can it be private
um there's a saying in Gold's case which
is it's the only financial asset that
you can own
um that is private and you can move
around that
um isn't dependent on somebody paying
you money paying you something
so as a medium of exchange so uh crypto
those in a Fiat world uh naturally
becomes a alternative uh consideration
and the fact that it's gone on uh
something like Bitcoin I guess about 11
years and and it hasn't been hacked and
it you know is working in that way has
its particular appeal it has big issues
it's not a it's not a private asset and
it is
um easily outlawed it it doesn't
constitute a high enough percentage of
wealth that um right now for example
bitcoin's worth maybe
700 billion dollars or so on which makes
it a small asset by comparison to a lot
of things like Microsoft is worth more
than
um crypto is and so it's not it hasn't
reached those uh particular stages I
think that um people are grappling for
what the new money will be in this
environment and I think we don't know
yet what the new money is I think we're
going to see different countries put out
their different versions of digital
countries occurrencies and then there
will be private assets and and gold will
play a role the important thing is we
have entered an era
um which will carry us through the next
number of years of what is the money
that is widely accepted uh as a medium
of exchange and a viable storehold of
wealth